a wisecrack Jared and Carnot again and
we've got another wisecrack quick take
on this week's Rick and Morty episode
pickle Rick
I'm pickle Rick I'm here to answer the
question why does Rick turn into a
pickle and yes it's partly because Dan
Harmon said Rick is a pickle and a
writers room brainstorm and then there's
the other easy answer to avoid family
therapy but if you stick with me I'm
going to argue that Rick's being as
pickle can teach us a lot about freedom
welcome to this wisecrack quick take on
pickle rick and of course spoilers ahead
but first a recap Rick if you couldn't
deduce has turned himself into a pickle
to get out of family therapy but things
go awry and the ends up fighting his way
out of a sewer and later a Russian
embassy using a mech suit made out of
Roche parts and rat limbs meanwhile Beth
Summer and Morty have to go to family
therapy after summer huffed pottery
enamel and morty peed his pants there's
a clever parallel between beth and rick
in this episode just as rick goes to
insane lengths to avoid baring his
emotions in therapy Beth is doing her
best to Stonewall her school appointed
therapist and maintain her emotional
distance I think it's possible that you
and your father have a very specific
dynamic I don't think it's one that
rewards emotion or vulnerability I think
it may punish them I think it's possible
that dynamic you roted your marriage and
it's infecting your kids with the
tendency to misdirect their feelings you
mom both of you - one thing we've
noticed in the season is that there's
more emphasis on serialized arcs in the
last episode Rick is willing to stay in
Mad Max land to avoid dealing with his
daughters divorce my daughter's going
through a divorce and I am NOT dealing
with it in a healthy way at all
now he's literally turned himself into a
pickle to run away from reality and
Morty and summers seem increasingly
damaged by their parents divorce I am
mad that I can't Huff enamel without
people assuming it's because my family
sucks with this continuation we've
noticed a few themes that seem to be
slowly developing one of which is
freedom this quote from dr. Wong really
sets the stage for our discussion I
think it's because the only truly
unapproachable concept for you is that
it's your mind
within your control you chose to come
here you chose to talk to belittle my
vocation just as you chose to become a
pickle each of us gets to choose at
first dr. Wong's monologue seemed a
little strange after all how could Rick
not understand that he's in control he
can do anything including turn himself
into a pickle
the reason anyone would do this if they
could which they can't would be because
they could which they can't but after
digging through my notes on the ugliest
of existential philosophers I think dr.
Long's monologue gets us to something
quite insightful as we all know Rick
doesn't believe in God there is no God
summer gotta rip that band-aid off now
you'll thank me later
and for philosopher jean-paul Sartre
godlessness means we are radically free
to define our own existence but instead
we choose to do things based on social
pressures or who we think we're supposed
to be in all kinds other Bulls Sartre
calls this acting in bad faith but since
we're mortal there's a fixed amount of
choices to make in our lives
what Sartre calls finitude and each of
those choices prevents other choices
choosing to be a truck driver means
choosing not to be a teacher to deny the
importance of our finite choices is
another way to act in bad faith often we
pretend to not have a choice as West
Side Story puts it kindly sergeant
Krupke you gotta understand it's just I
bring an update that gets us out of hand
our mothers are junkies our fathers all
are drunks essentially the hoodlums know
they're acting like a bunch of little
shits but instead of choosing to be
better they relinquish their choice and
blame it on their negligent parents they
just can't help themselves
but what's unique about Rick is that he
doesn't deal with finitude he deals with
infinitude my access to infinite
timelines precludes the necessity of
attachment rick has to grapple with the
exact opposite of what start proposed
because to call back to season one
there's an infinite number of realities
Morty whereas Sartre criticizes the
person who won't take responsibility for
their choices Rick thinks he doesn't
have to because he's already made them
and all the infinite versions of himself
if Sartre said the human condition was
one of finite choices well rick has
transcended that human condition with
science but as dr. Wong suggests just
buying your actions with the multiverse
or your god-like intelligence isn't a
solution because although intelligence
can help you make a decision you still
have to make the decision the only
connection between your unquestionable
intelligence and the sickness destroying
your family is that everyone in your
family you included use intelligence to
justify sickness despite the fact that
Rick is the master of his universe he
paradoxically has yet to come to terms
with his own choices no matter how many
versions of Rick exists nothing can stop
the fact that his choices are uniquely
his own because to quote dr. Wang the
only truly unapproachable concept for
you is that it's your mind within your
control in season one rigged straight-up
tells us how he deals with the infinite
choice in the multiverse what about the
reality where Hitler cured cancer Morty
the answer is don't think about it but
of course all therapy does is make you
think about things so Rick turns himself
into a pickle to avoid choice or at
least the appearance of it as a helpless
armless pickle it's not his fault if he
can't make therapy and in that sense
Rick's blatant disregard for his choices
as Sartre would say is acting in bad
faith speaking of Arc's this ties nicely
into what we talked about in the last
episode between Jerry's powerlessness
Morty's resentment of him for that very
reason and the juxtaposition with Rick
as an all-powerful madman I don't
respect therapy because I'm a scientist
because I invent transform create and
destroy for a living and when I don't
like something about the world I change
it this season is really leading into
ideas of agency and I'm super excited to
see what they come up with next there's
one last thing worth noting but it's
probably more of a stretch you know the
common characterization of Freud's work
as everything is a penis well I'm
convinced someone in their writers room
probably took this loose connection
between a phallic object in therapy and
point a little wild with it but if you
want to hear more about this you want to
check out the wisecrack podcast where
we're breaking down every new episode of
Rick and Morty
Ryan Alec and I talk further about all
the intricacies of this awesome episode
so check us out on iTunes or wherever
you get your podcasts thanks a lot for
all the support guys thanks for all the
recommendations thanks for all feedback
really appreciate it
see you later
[Music]